a new docu-series by tina knowles lawson
highlights the impact of harmful
stereotypes on black men she is an
executive producer of the series and oh
yeah she's also the mother of two
powerhouse daughters that would be
beyonce and solange profile the black
man uses real-life stories to explore
the history of stereotypes it highlights
the challenges that black men face
because of them it also shines a light
on people who are dedicating their lives
to changing that narrative the first
episode dismantles a damaging idea that
black men are dangerous
tina knowles lawson talks about the role
that the media plays on that and how
black men are portrayed so in this clip
she describes a very personal experience
involving questions about her son-in-law
we all know him as jay-z
i can remember getting on a plane and an
older white woman saying oh your son is
a gangster rapper right how did you let
him marry your daughter
and it was just shocking to me and i
said no actually my son is a ceo she
didn't think of him as a ceo or even a
talented celebrity that
you know was a great businessman and at
that time i remember thinking you know i
can't be mad at her because that is what
the media portrays
[Music]
tina knowles lawson is the executive
producer of the series and the
co-founder and artistic director of the
waco theater she's with us first on cbs
mornings tina my mouth fell open when
you gave that example because i'm
thinking and then you followed up by
saying i'm not even mad at her how are
you not mad and it's good to see you
tina it's good to see you
how are you not mad
a long time
uh
just because i thought you know i sat
there and i thought about how the media
portrays
black men and how
that is typical of the things that they
would focus on you know the negatives
and try to portray us as these dangerous
um
our men as dangerous uneducated gangster
rapper that's all she could come up with
but that's what she
you know that's what she had been saying
on tv and all in the media that's how
we're betrayed unfortunately so you're
saying you're saying we can't really
blame her i have to tell you we were
only allowed to see one part of the
series and i was so bummed tina because
by the time i watched the first one i
wanted to watch the other three it made
me angry it made me sad oddly enough
oddly enough i also found it uplifting
and i'm wondering i've heard you say
that this you wanted this to be a love
letter to black men so your goal here is
what exactly
absolutely to debunk those stereotypes
that our men are dangerous you know if
how many times has a black man walked
into an elevator and someone clutches
their purse or they walk by a car
and
you know the door is not locked and they
could be a judge they could be they they
have no idea but because it's a black
man especially if they're of some
stature um that they're dangerous and so
if we can kind of
get people to understand that that's not
so and to show them examples of
otherwise that we are we do have good
fathers and we are good providers and we
love our you know our men love their own
women as well um it's just all the
negative stereotypes and and it's
it's just perpetuated over and over
no matter what yeah it it's just what
everybody thinks
you know and the other thing i liked
about
no i'm sorry go ahead gail
no the the other thing i liked about it
is you gave example after example to
illustrate the point of the disparities
that exist for black men and one thing
that i found really striking you had a
black man and a white man who have the
same build weighed the same had the same
body build but yet when the audience was
asked when the survey was asked people
automatically said that the black man
was muscular was more muscular and
looked more dangerous which i found
fascinating when you have two side by
side with looking the same way other
than the color of their skin what do we
do to change that way of thinking
well i think you know when trail brought
this trail thomas is the guy who
actually
talked about these problems and wanted
to do something so badly to develop
these stereotypes and i was like if you
don't see it created and and we'll get
together we'll work on this and and make
it a great thing
um what i said to to the producers is
that i know
that if we put this series on bt or one
of the black stations that we already
know that our men are not dangerous and
that they are good fathers and all of
these things
who needs to see it are the people that
are at home the white people who don't
understand that that is so and they have
been fed a lot of nonsense through the
media and all of these horrible
stereotypes so i applaud um
the network
for
putting that on um the discovery channel
that's amazing
it's bold yeah i think so too
because i hope that
many many people will see this and they
will say wow
maybe i'll give people a chance before i
judge them because because of the color
of their skin yep
yep i i really i have to say to and i'm
not just saying this tina because you're
sitting here in front of me but it it's
so well done i think it's must-see tv i
know tony in the studio do you have a
question for tina yeah gail thank you
very much tina thank you very much for
being here my question is is a quick one
it took us hundreds of years to get to
this problematic point how soon how
quickly do you think we can get past it
oh my god
i you know sometimes i have a lot of
hope and then i look at turn on the news
that day and
my hope is is kind of shattered so i
pray that it's going to happen soon um i
pray that everybody will open their
minds and open their hearts and you know
everyone will try to get together and
see each other as people and not do
a lot of color
but i don't know i don't i'm not as
optimistic as i was yesterday
yeah i know
tina i understand that i just want to
say before you go
10 years ago you told me that your
oldest daughter your favorite oldest
daughter said that you said she works
harder than anybody you know
anybody you know and i've never
forgotten that about how hard beyonce
works she's been nominated for an oscar
what was the reaction in the family as
we go to break what was the reaction
um
my reaction is that i thought she should
have got one many times before so i'm
not you know it's nice
yes tina
we agree thank you tina knows lawson
profile the black man premieres this
saturday